[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salehs
wessels ich bin eure muss nachgegangen
und habe heute eine einhorn torte für
euch und ich hab mir ein bisschen damit
zeit gelassen aber ich wollte die
perfekte 100 torte backen und habe
deswegen mit samira eine kleine skizze
gefertigt hier ist unser einhorn mit
schönen regenbogen haaren und hier ist
das 3c einhorn ich habe es ein hund
lebens gemacht das heißt den kopf damit
ihr es auch einfach nachmachen könnt und
ich glaube mit ein bisschen übung
schafft jetzt auch ihren steckte ein
saftiger zitronenkuchen mit konfetti
streuseln gefüllt habe ich die torte mit
einem lemon körper also einer
zitronencreme und eingestrichen mit
einer weißen schokoladen gemischt dh die
torte ist nicht nur hübsch von außen
sondern auch richtig lecker von innen
und die haare habe ich modelliert aus
modelle schokolade oder teilweise aus
fondant und natürlich auch das schöne
goldene einhorn aus blüten passt und
gefällt mir so wirklich richtig gut und
ich traue mich fast gar nichts die torte
später am ende anzuschneiden ich habe
das ganze auf zwei tage verteilt gemacht
das heißt am ersten tag die böden
gebacken und die cremes vorbereitet auch
das einhorn gemacht und am zweiten tag
dann dekoriert also wenn ihr euch das
auch so aufteilen
dann klappt es wirklich wunderbar und
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten für den rührteig für den teig
brauch ich sechs eier 300 was vanille
extrakt eine prise salz 400 gramm mehl
ich habe ich 200 gramm gemahlene mandeln
ein päckchen backpulver eine
unbehandelte zitrone jeweils 300
milliliter sonnenblumenöl und
buttermilch und hier habe ich 15
esslöffeln von bunten streuseln in den
verschiedensten schönen farben ich nehme
jetzt die eier mit zucker salz und
vanille extrakt und verrühren die
zutaten für etwa vier bis fünf minuten
zu einer schaumigen masse
[Musik]
sobald die eier wasser dann weiß bringen
hier ist schaltet die geschwindigkeiten
bissen runter und gebt die zwei
flüssigkeit mit dazu
[Musik]
sobald die zutaten verrührt sind kommen
jetzt die trockenen zutaten mit dazu
mehl und backpulver vermischen sich
jetzt um 17 durch und die mandeln habe
ich bereits fein gemahlen und die
zitronenschale wird jetzt auch
abgerieben und ganz kurz ein gerührt
[Musik]
und zum schluss kommen noch die zucker
streusel mitteilen
ich habe zwei baukräne vorbereitet
einmal mit 26 und mit 20 cm durchmesser
und den teig fühle ich jetzt zu drei
viertel in die große form und zu einem
viertel in die kleine vor meinen da der
teig sehr flüssig jetzt ist es völlig in
ordnung dass da unten so ein ganz
kleiner rand austritt und so weiter im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze gebacken
der große braucht etwa 50 minuten der
kleine etwa 30 35 minuten schaut einfach
auf die uhr stellt euch die zeit und
macht auf jeden fall besteht schon probe
mit dem verstopfen
wer jetzt noch im backofen backt werde
ich schon einmal die deko vorbereiten
und zwar das einhorn das einhorn muss
gut durchtrocknen daher bereit
deutschland fort und nehme dafür einfach
blöd taste und löten passte muss ich
jetzt nur etwas weich kneten traum ich
es zu einer langen rolle und die rolle
sonst schon gleichmäßig sein
[Musik]
da blüten passe sehr schnell trocknet
solltet ihr die übrige die nicht
verwendet einfach immer gut luftdicht
verschließen
gegen ende hin darf die rolle und ein
bisschen dünner werden
aber das mache ich jetzt gleich noch da
ich noch nicht weiß wie lange sie wird
jetzt nehme ich hier einen
schillerlocken förmchen und zwar kann
man damit wunderbar gepäck zu bereiten
oder eben auch hier dieses einen machen
falls er kein schnäppchen habt könnt ihr
auch zum beispiel ein stück pappe rollen
mit tesa verkleben und das ganze dann
auch beendet
damit dies nach dem trocknen wieder
wegbekommen bestrich wachstum spray
entwickelt ihr diese rolle einfach um
das schiller löckchen herum und drückt
es dabei ganz ganz vorsichtig fest
und wenn ihr merkt es geht dem ende zu
knipst ihr es einfach ab und formt das
ende so ein bisschen dünner und formt
daraus dann die schöne später
jetzt stelle ich das horn hier einfach
ab und kann es über nacht oder über zwei
tage gegen weg einfach gut trocknen
lassen und jetzt wartet nur noch auf den
kuchen im ofen den werde ich gleich
heraus nehmen sobald er gebacken ist
ihnen auf ein abkühlt aussetzen und den
tortenring einfach noch drum herum
lassen zum abkühlen und mit einem
sauberen geschäft aufdecken
so kann dann nämlich über nacht hier
einfach bei zimmertemperatur stehen
bleiben die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt
auch noch um werte nach meinem
grundrezept ein level gehört und eine
weisse gams herstellen und dann geht's
am nächsten tag gleich weiter jetzt habe
ich die torten würden die weiße garage
und auch das level könnt über nacht
abkühlen lassen
ich hatte die tortenböden abgedeckt mit
einem sauberen geschirrtuch und wenn es
jetzt gleich aus der form herauslösen
das einzige was jetzt noch fehlt ist der
zitronen sirup da habe ich jetzt hier
für 100 milliliter zitronensaft frisch
ausgepresst es gibt ihn in einen topf
und da gebe ich einfach noch zucker mit
dazu im prinzip braucht ihr denn sehr
oft gar nicht aber dann macht den teig
einfach noch ein bisschen saftiger und
so kann ich die motiv torte auch drei
vier tage im kühlschrank aufbewahren
ohne dass sie einfach trocken wird es so
den lasse ich jetzt hier einfach kurz
einkochen und kann in der zwischenzeit
schon mal hier die tortenböden
herauslösen
[Musik]
die tortenböden habe ich jetzt mit einer
torten säge durchgeschnitten und jetzt
werde ich sie befüllen dafür nämlich
jetzt eine tortenplatte das ist ein
dünner karton der auch ganz gut fürs
präsentieren die torte geeignet ist und
der muss ist aber groß genug sein damit
die ganze torte draufpasst das heißt ich
nehme jetzt einmal meine vorlage habe
ich mir gestern gezeichnet und hab da
eben auch schon ein bisschen mit den
farben herumgespielt und samira hat mit
mir zusammen gemacht
und weil das eben ein
gemeinschaftsprojekt von samira auto mir
ist werde ich dieses exemplar nicht
zerschneiden von dann habe es mir hier
nochmal darauf gedruckt also drauf
gepasst sage jetzt mal und im prinzip
passt das dann von der größe her
man muss sich nämlich vorstellen da
kommt auch die mähne drauf also die
haarpracht und da ist es schon ganz gut
bisschen großzügiger zu sein so ich muss
jetzt mir merken hier kommt der kopf
drauf das heißt ich muss jetzt hier im
endeffekt den größeren kuchen drauf
machen
dafür nehme ich jetzt die weiße
schokoladen ganache und streicht sich
hier drauf damit die torte schön an
orten sport festklebt eine komplette
erste booten drauf
und jetzt werde ich die torten würden
jeweils mit dem sirup bestreichen
einfach mit einem pinsel so ein bisschen
was bringt ein bisschen die frische in
die torte da kommen da ein bisschen
lemon curt drauf und ihr seht schon an
der farbe das jetzt etwas mehr butter
drin als jetzt nur beim reinen
brotaufstrich und da steht dann wird das
rezept auch auf meinem blog
die butter deswegen damit die creme auch
ein bisschen fester wird im kühlschrank
[Musik]
damit der zweite boden und so wird jetzt
die torte komplett gefüllt wir können
sie auch im prinzip wenn jetzt kein lamm
kalb möchte auch einfach nur mit der
ghanaer spielfilm
[Musik]
die schablone aber ich jetzt geschnitten
jetzt kann ich sie mir hier drauf legen
und praktisch dem zweiten kuchen hier
drauf machen und zwar müsse darauf
achten dass der kopfbereich einfach ein
bisschen dicker ist und der maul bereich
ein bisschen dünner
das heißt ich nehme jetzt einfach immer
wieder teig setzt es dran und clips mit
der ganache fest
[Musik]
so steht jetzt erst einmal die
grundstruktur und damit die anderen
kuchen weiter arbeiten kann und ihnen
auch zurechtschneiden kann und
modellieren kann muss ich ihn erst
einmal kühlen
dafür gebe ich ihnen jetzt einfach für
eine halbe stunde ins gefrierfach das
geht nämlich am schnellsten
jetzt ist der kuchen gut durchgeführt
und ich kann jetzt hier weitermachen
jetzt müsst ihr euch das ganze wie so
einen 3d coop eben auch vorstellen also
der kopf ist schon rund die schnauze
abgerundet der halle sind dünner als der
kopf dass der kopf muss erhöhter sein
und so werde ich es in kuchen
zurechtschneiden immer wieder mit ghanas
bestreichen zeit wegschneiden woanders
wieder ankleben so dass eben ein schöner
3d kopf entsteht
[Musik]
am besten könnt ihr arbeiten wenn ihr
die torte immer mal wieder mit ghanas
bestreicht und sie dann zum kühlen in
den kühlschrank oder im gefrierfach
stellt damit die ganz fest und die wirkt
als so eine art kleber und als
stabilisator und da könnte er wieder
ganz normal weiterarbeiten
[Musik]
jetzt kann man schon ganz grob erkennen
das ist ein einhorn wird und jetzt lege
ich hier immer mal wieder die schablone
drauf und schaue jetzt einfach dass ich
die feinheiten machen die feinheiten
mache ich es mit nudeln schokolade
die ist nämlich ganz gut weil sie im
kühlschrank eben auch aushärtet das
heißt wenn sie kalt ist ist sie schon
fest und wenn ich sie kneten mit den
händen war mache dann ist das schön
weich und das nehme ich jetzt und
formatierten für die nase den mund oder
auch das augenlid und mache so die torte
im prinzip fertig für den von dampf
[Musik]
ich habe ist die torte für den versand
vorbereitet und jetzt nochmal
einheimischen natur und in der
zwischenzeit schon mal meine freundin
und meine dicke sachen hierher bringen
und hier alles richtig
das bett ist durch gekühlt ich habe
jetzt hier ein kilo weizen von band
bereits weiß geknetet und werden jetzt
auf becker stärke ausrollen und dann
gleich übers bett überlegen
jetzt kann ich die torte nehmen
und weil sie jetzt schön trocken ist
nehme ich jetzt etwas wachstums pay und
sprüht sie ein zu hatte davon dann
besser drauf und ich vermeide es wo auch
viele luft medien
[Musik]
jetzt fahre ich mit den händen die
konturen nach und nehmen dann auch
modelle werkzeug um die feinheiten ein
bisschen besser darzustellen
[Musik]
jetzt eigentlich mit der ausgestaltung
an als f das mache ich jetzt das auge
und zwar nehme ich jetzt für das auge
etwas flöten passte weil die einfach
schnell trocknet weil sie eben auch eine
große fläche ist das heißt in dem jetzt
entsprechend den menge wollte sie zur
kugel und dann passe ich sie an
und wer es mit esswaren kleber eben auch
ankleben ich habe ich jetzt blüten
passte blau und schwarz eingefärbt und
steckt jetzt kreisförmig aus um sie dann
hier abgegeben
fürs auge habe ich jetzt hier noch ein
lied geformt auch auf blüten passte und
das werde ich jetzt hier an bringen und
mit schwarzer blüten passt da nicht die
wimpern formen und mit schwarzer farbe
noch ein paar schattierungen und
feinheiten machen
[Musik]
das gesicht ist jetzt schon mal fertig
jetzt fehlen praktisch nur noch die
haare das ohr und das einhorn und
deswegen werde ich jetzt zuerst einmal
diese skateboard noch schön dekorieren
denn ich finde eine torte muss nicht nur
gut aussehen gut schmecken auch das
skateboard muster zu fassen weil ich
finde so weit dass jetzt nicht so ganz
schön und später hat man einfach ein
schönes einheitliches ergebnis um das
skateboard jetzt zu überziehen können
jetzt zum beispiel von hand nehmen
ich bevorzuge heute ein racing das heißt
eine eiweiß sprits klasse
die besteht aus drei zutaten nämlich
butter zucker eiweiß und etwas wasser
jetzt habe ich hier puderzucker gebe ein
bisschen eiweißpulver mit dazu so muss
ich kein rohes ei weißdorn und jetzt nur
noch so viel wasser dass eine schöne
streichfähige masse entsteht
[Musik]
jetzt ist dickler so fertig einen teil
lasse ich weiß und den rest hebe ich
hellblau ein und streicht das einfach
schön auf diese skateboard dass es so
eine art himmel optik bekommt
[Musik]
das horn ist jetzt auch einigermaßen
durchgetrocknet jetzt kann ich hier ganz
vorsichtig ablösen
man könnte auch mal innen fühlen das ist
fast ganz trocken
ich stecke jetzt trotzdem noch mal auf
damit ich einfach mehr stabilität habt
zum arbeiten und jetzt wird's gold weil
ich ein zu dunkles gold haben möchte und
auch kein zu helles sondern eher so
mittel ton nehme ich einmal so eine
metallic farbe als grundierung und dann
das farbpulver das kommt dann obendrauf
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem einhorn
jetzt kommt zuerst einmal die haarpracht
und jetzt habe ich hier sechs farben aus
von und vorbereitet in den von dort habe
ich immer einen halben teelöffel cmc
verein geknetet einfach damit davon dann
zur modelliermasse wird und so ein
bisschen aushärtet und die form behält
ich habe erzählt die farben pink orange
lila blau grün und gelb
und das weiß noch ich später für die
ohren das orange habe ich gemischt aus
gelb und rot lila und pink habe ich dann
ein färben müssen ausweisen sondern und
den rest dann gibt's ja schon so und
blaue dieses blau das ist die modelle
schokolade
die habe ich gewählt weil es einfach so
richtig wunderschönes blau ist also so
ein bisschen in die art ja geht es in
richtung türkis und modelliert
schokolade eignet sich auch hervorragend
außerdem ist immer kleine stückchen die
habe ich bereits weiß geknetet und form
sie dann zu einer strähne vorne hübsche
spitze dran und dass wir dann gleich zu
einer locke geformt das heißt ich mache
jetzt einfach mal ein paar und kann sie
dann schön anklicken
[Musik]
bei den strähnen solltet ihr euch das
jetzt so vorstellen ihr solltet euch
einen punkt nehmen ich nehme jetzt zb
hier am hinterkopf und werden von hier
aus strähnen nach vorne laufen lassen
und auch nach hinten und das ganze mit
essbarem kleber ankleben
[Musik]
die päckchen habe ich jetzt einigermaßen
fertig ein paar kommen gleich noch
sobald das einhorn und das ohr dran ist
jetzt habe ich hier ein stück
modelliermasse das heißt fondant und
blüten pasta gemischt und werdet das ohr
formen das ohr kann man jetzt auch
vorher machen damit es durch trocknet
aber ich finde es ganz gut wenn man weiß
wo man es platzieren möchte und wie groß
es sein wird ist dann einfach nur mal
frisch zu machen
ich freue mich hier raus einen tropfen
und mache hier oben einfach so eine
vertiefung rein
[Musik]
wenn ihr damit der form zufrieden seid
hebt jetzt einfach mal dran
bei mir passt selbst von der größe her
und von der form ist lasse ich es kurz
antrocknen und dadurch dass ich jetzt
blüten passt damit dabei hab das auch
ganz gut und wenn ihr jetzt nicht so ein
kleines schälchen habt dann nehmt
einfach einen kleinen teller oder
bastelt was aus küchenrolle oder
alufolie und könnte es da schon trocknen
lassen
das einzige was ich jetzt noch machen
werde er ist mit etwas pulver farbe des
orts sortieren
[Musik]
jetzt ist das organ getrocknet und nicht
existiert dran kleben und zur
verstärkung nämlich einen zahnstocher
den werde es in die torte reinstecken
[Musik]
hier möchte ich gerne dass es einfach
noch ein kleines herz auf die wange
bekommt dafür nämlich ist ein
lebensmittel farbstift ihr könnt das
jetzt auch nur mit dem machen also
praktisch aufzeichnen und anmalen
das kamel zu lassen oder ihr nehmt jetzt
noch mal die zucker schrift in rosa oder
in roth dieser so ein bisschen plastisch
macht das ganze 3d und soweit ich das
jetzt machen
und weil es eben sehr fein und filigran
ist trage ich sie jetzt mit dem pinsel
auf
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich das horn und ich werde
euch jetzt empfehlen falls ihr die torte
transportieren möchte dann transportiert
sie so dass horn separat und fügt dann
einfach am ende noch dazu ich gucke
jetzt erst einmal ob es wundert größe
her passt passt hier wunderbar und ich
werde es jetzt nicht dran kleben sondern
nur dran stecken das heißt ich nehme
jetzt wieder zahnstocher steckt die
ihnen die torten wäre dann das horn
einfach dran heben so kann ich einfach
sichergehen dass es unterwegs jetzt
nicht kaputt geht und ich kann dann eben
auch ganz einfach wieder entfernen und
ich glaube das gefällt ja auch so ganz
vielen das heißt die prinzessin zum
beispiel die dieses einkommen zum
geburtstag bekommt kann dass frauen
einfach ins zimmer stellen und auf leben
und hier unten lege ich jetzt einfach
noch so eine blaue modellierte monat
dahin eine kleine kugel kann jetzt
darauf schützen
das mache ich gleich rein und das sieht
dann noch
jetzt schaue ich nur noch wo noch ein
paar leutchen vielleicht fehlen um das
ganze richtig auszugestalten und dann
ist das eine hand schon fertig
seid ihr bereit gefällt dir die torte
[Musik]
will sie eigentlich auch nicht aber ohne
brille das mindeste mit schreiben würde
verbuchen und viele fragen sich jetzt
verstehen wir sind die torte von innen
aus und es ist ja kein echtes einhorn
okay da wir können sehr wieder packen
also ich schneide
[Musik]
in den schönen bunten die besondere
füllung ist die zitrone lernen kann geht
mir mal deinen teller stürzen stückchen
habe aber die gabel leser aus es ist ein
kleines stück samir naja okay sagt auch
stein steckte der kuchen der ist doch
richtig richtig also kein politisch sagt
ich soll nicht so in zu drucken
und ich finde die kleinen zuckerstücke
kohl der vertreter aus 100 lesen müssen
jetzt in tacen dies kann ganz viel glück
diese gier zu dem thema ja mit streu
becker mit bunten und super sagt keiner
mal nicht mal hier
die haut sich hier das stück ich glaube
es schmeckt mir da wird eben schon die
schnauze essen das fand ich ein bisschen
portale und so hatte ich glaube auch
dass jedes kind und jeder erwachsene von
dieser torte begeistert sein würde
wir werden die torte jetzt ja was machen
wir damit wir werden jetzt meine eltern
zuerst noch einladen
dieses geld kommt heute noch vorbei eine
freundin von mir und da werden wir
später die torte alle zusammen essen
jeder macht eigentlich vom eingang habe
und langsam genug da ja schatz langsam
ist kamprad vom kindergarten flächen
jetzt gibt's gleich essen also falls ihr
das rezept nach machen wollt findet ihr
alle mengenangaben noch mal in meinem
blog auf meinem blog auch sallys -
blog.de und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal bis dann
[Musik]
gebrochen scheint zu schmecken samira
stopps langsam
[Musik]